this weave is killing me it's good weed
they're gonna kill the good weed now
right is that what's happening how's
this work I still got some guys yeah I'm
sure you do absolutely but legally for
it'll still be available for medicinal
people who have so we got to get a card
yeah recreational it's gonna be ever new
that car at Sun I got that card I don't
want any [ __ ] weed I don't want to
eat your [ __ ] watered-down weed what
are they gonna do they gotta water it
down
how much 18% something like that but
never fear but here's the thing isn't
that strong Joey's here look we got a DA
one two oh wow who you think you're
dealing with here
Joey bananas we got state/federal we got
them coming from all over you lose I am
damn da [ __ ] yeah just in case just in
case just in case we're in the [ __ ]
Tom Cruise's american-made medicinal
rules in Ohio recently you can't grow
your own there if you have a card yeah
they're sneaky with that [ __ ] right yeah
hopefully people eventually vote that
out but you had to get it in there first
that's the only way it would have passed
they have everything wired up but it's a
it's a victory because it's very gonna
be very difficult to make it illegal now
that it's legal it's gonna be very
difficult to go backwards so then you
have to figure out like why do these
companies have a monopoly on making it
if it's legal why can't you make it
yourself aren't Tomatoes legal I can
grow tomatoes can I you can even
probably grows like do you need a tax
stamp or something to grow tobacco how
does that work like if you wanted to
grow your own tobacco would you be able
to do that like if you said I want to
make my own [ __ ] pipes and uh you
know fill them with my own tobacco I
want to make my own cigars could you do
that it's not possible for personal use
that's crazy so if you could do that
federally and then they're saying you
can't in Ohio you can't grow your own
weed that's so stupid
that's so dumb we do you even know what
you do I don't know dick about it I
wouldn't do it but you should be able to
if it's legal
course you should be able to grow it
that's it's a [ __ ] plan we might not
throw it where can you not grow in Ohio
if you have a card here's the worry the
worry is that you wouldn't charge taxes
you would keep the money you wouldn't be
accurate you just do with cash you do
cash transactions that's the worry but
that would be a tax worry more that
right so what is it that were the same
tobacco - yeah you can grow as much as
you want you just can't sell it okay but
you did not even allowed to grow their
own for personal use when it comes to
marijuana so it's more restrictive than
tobacco which is HIGHlarious
silly [ __ ] that's so dumb does that
make any sense to you we have some wacky
laws that we let sneak through like why
would you let other people decide that
different people in this group can't
grow a plant that's legal now get the
[ __ ] out of here
that's dumb that's a dumb rule they
can't something edibles over a hundred
no weed that's loose anymore so if I
come into your store and I go what do
you got you can't open up the container
you show me the button let me smell it
they all have to be sealed and stuff
there's just a lot of silly rules I
don't know which ones they don't I'm
very hot happy I found this bag of
expired [ __ ] chibi choose 2015 listen
you know may I make it work
are they diminished in any way no no
couple have a little bit of mold on them
you just take the mold off I put a
little brown nail polish on it nobody
knows nothing you seen it like it like
nothing who gives a [ __ ] a little Mole
never killed nobody molds help people
yeah that song came from some mold
didn't it it's not like that